president Trump just wrapping up a
meeting with FBI director Chris Rea
Deputy Attorney General rod Rosenstein
and Director of National Intelligence
dan coates at the White House this comes
as the president is demanding answers
over a series of reports that an FBI
informant was in contact with Associates
of his campaign Trump tweeting that the
DOJ needs to investigate if his campaign
was quote infiltrated or surveilled and
if the Obama administration was involved
the DOJ is responding by asking its
Inspector General to look into these
allegations vice president Mike Pence is
reacting to the latest developments in a
sit-down with martha maccallum the
president I think is grateful that the
Department of Justice is going to have
the Inspector General look into it and
determine and ensure that there was no
surveillance done for political purposes
against our campaign I think it would be
very troubling to millions of Americans
that that took place House Committee
Chairman Devin Nunez is saying if this
is true it is a major scandal if they
ran a spy ring or an informant ring and
they were paying people within the Trump
campaign if any of that is true that is
an absolute redline you can't do this to
political campaigns I mean this was done
I mean according to them this was done
in in the spring
I mean before the counterintelligence
investigation was even open if that's
true we need to know about it meanwhile
former DOJ officials Sally Yates is
losing it over president Trump's
requests I think what we're seeing here
is the president has just taken his
all-out assault on the rule of law to a
new level and this time he is ordering
up an investigation of the investigators
who are examining his own campaign you
know that's really shocking
all right so you'd expect people from
the Obama administration to say things
like that director former CIA director
John Brennan also lashed out on Twitter
but if this information is correct
Kimberly how devastating would it be for
our intelligence agencies I'm you know
it's quite disconcerting isn't it when
you think about that if there was
actually an active spy op or
within a campaign you would hope that if
they thought that there was something
that was at risk you know with respect
to Russian intelligence that they would
in fact go to candidate Trump at the
time or some official within the
campaign and say listen we have some
information and belief that perhaps your
campaign could have an issue and someone
could try to get involved or try to get
intelligence from you etc but that
didn't happen so it's sort of just
really belies the the truth accuracy of
it and then you saw the New York Times
sort of preempt put this out there in
advance of the IG report which is
expected to be quite damning right so
they put this out they say well this is
why we were doing it really looking out
for you we're looking to protect you but
it just doesn't ring true does it
because it just seems why wouldn't you
be transparent and tell them instead of
sort of trying to catch or entrap or do
something like that what the FBI's job
is not to spy on you know campaigns or
place somebody within an organization
like that it's just simply completely
out of bounds right Comey said he was
suspicious in the spring of 2016
decided not to inform the campaign in
the spring that that Russians might be
up to something and then they looked at
Papadopoulos I think in July or August
Gregg and they didn't even interview him
until January they waited six months why
not if Papadopoulos had heard something
why not just ask him straight up what's
going on well first the more that they
keep trying to find collusion the more
they find Democrats and this this
scandal or the pseudo scandal whatever
it turns out to be it's actually easier
to explain to the American public than
all of the other collusion stuff they
sent an informant in to trap Trump is
easier to explain I love the media
explanation for this
we were only so we only sent this
informant in there to protect Donald
Trump we were spying on you as a favor
that's I saying I'm stalking you as a
favor I stole your car so no one else
would steal your car it's actually the
plot of national treasure when Nicholas
Cage stole the Declaration of
Independence
so being what's his name Sean beans gang
wouldn't take it I get that as a movie
but here it's a bit absurd so why did
this happen why did why did Brennan if
it was Brennan why did they do this
setup why did they set the trap I
believe that they thought that they were
doing God's
work that they were energized by the
frantic alarmist media about Trump of
which I include myself in it because I
was every bit as like worried about
Trump as anybody during the campaign so
I have to say that I'm part of that
alarmist media I think if you watch the
news and you're a part of the news and
you were part of the government you
convinced yourself that a Perret if
Trump became president the country was
in peril and therefore doing something
like this which was illegal is actually
patriotic that's what struck himself
Texas yes yeah I need to save the
country you have a Trump but they now
they're wrong I admit I was wrong so
they got admit they're wrong they might
have to go to jail yeah you're making
more money than usual so the DOJ to do
this flipping the script essentially
what will this do to the Muller
investigation does this hasten the end
of it does this elongate it how do you
see a going I saw Chris Christie doing
an interview today where he said that
he's given President Trump a lot of
advice and that he said that there he
tells them there are ways to shorten
this investigation and ways to make it
longer and it's so far President Trump
has taken every step to make it longer
so I don't know I don't know if when
Rudy Giuliani said this weekend that
Buller told me it'll be wrapped up by
September first Michael I don't even
know if I would say that because do you
want to hang out this whole summer and I
I am willing to believe that the Obama
team mm-hmm had done this right that
they were like politically activated but
all of these things of if it's true if
it's true if it's reminds me of they
wiretap me at Trump Tower which turns
out not to have been the case I guess we
don't know I mean unless maybe in the
whole investigation we find out that
somebody on the campaign did have a
wiretap or something like that had an
apartment at Trump Tower yeah well then
maybe there's an empire man aboard I
think they probably I'm I'm one that is
willing to wait for the evidence and I
think if the Inspector General who
everyone seems to admire at least so far
until they say something that he doesn't
like okay that everyone thinks that he's
doing a pretty good job we're waiting
for the report that he has on Hillary
Clinton's emails it should come out any
day now maybe like it by today and
within the hour I do think that the
Hillary Clinton team has a right to be
somewhat mad
that they their position is you need to
tell me that the FBI was willing to go
out on the record with the director to
say that I was being and that I was
being investigated by Hillary Clinton
and meanwhile they played down New York
Times inquiries about the Trump team
being under investigation for a Russian
collusion yeah I don't think they
thought Trump was gonna win well I don't
who the FBI Hillary I didn't know to
that point I think Hillary should be
upset that the government didn't send a
spy into her campaign to protect her
detector from herself exactly the email
issue according to the media Greg it was
not a spy it was just an informant right
Wang that's true just an informant what
and also I mean just this set the record
straight because Donald Trump president
Crump said embedded there was nobody
embedded in the campaign this guy is a
professor or somewhere in Britain and
what he did was he came into contact
with three officials three of whom had
already previously been implicated in
terms of connections to Russia we heard
it was four officials well okay I'll go
with three I'll go with Carter Paige
I'll go with George papadopolis right
and who's the other the other two of
linen metaphor there was another one
okay embedded and you talked to four
campaign people
Sam's a lot clovis know Sam close that's
the other one thank you no so but the
point is nobody was embedded and so what
you have is a legitimate investigation
to the idea that Russia is interfering
in an American election and they don't
launch by the way a criminal
investigation they do a
counterintelligence investigation and so
all they're doing is trying to find out
what's going on now the thing that
concerns me and I and I pick up on this
run I think this is what Sally Yates was
talking about is you know what we rely
on our intelligence people and people
who are sources and if you start outing
them this comes from Christopher
remember Trump's guy at FBI you do that
you put the American people he put the
American public at great risk if we
can't protect our agents yet they made
it pretty clear who he was in a number
of ways by the way if they really did
care if they really did care there would
have been fair about this and they would
have they would have dealt with it both
campaigns you could they could win now
they're saying now like oh the Russians
were more interested in Trump but that's
convenient sure now that everybody finds
out that you've been putting right
everybody from the demócratas in Senate
committee has said Russia favored Warren
and Donald Trump to win we learned this
weekend the Saudis the Israelis also
were saying yeah we we have an interest
in helping you out mr. Trump here's a
fact one a week after the DNC server was
allegedly hacked by the Russians they
open up a counterintelligence
investigation to see about Russian
hacking but Kimberly
they never seized the server they never
looked at the server Ranna investigation
on the server determined whether or not
it was indeed hack didn't you think
wouldn't you think that would be the
first thing they did think because
they're looking into Russian actual
evidence there's a how about turn over
the physical tangible evidence so they
can do a proper forensic examination and
see if they can delete any retrieve file
you know retrieve any deleted files etc
so it just really just shows the
hypocrisy and how disingenuous because
when they have evidence of actual
malfeasance and things going on they
don't do anything about it but then they
try and conjure up like evil spirits an
idea of collusion and then say just look
it out for you buddy
and they put someone in your campaign so
they're changing the story saying no no
no we're just trying to protect you but
no wait it was an informant but it's not
a spy but it's I mean it's verbal you
know gymnastics see through it none of
this none of this changes anything
you know what I mean I don't think it
changes a bit so we still are dealing
with the idea that Russians tried to
interfere in campaign we're still
waiting to find out what Muller has and
what we have is the president and his
aides throwing this up and everybody
says well now the president says this
maybe that we didn't maybe this threw
this up this was a leak from no no
people in the Intelligence Committee in
the New York
in the Washington Post get out ahead of
this because this is all coming up I'll
tell you why I hereby order my own
Justice Department shirt now the Justice
Department's a political tool though it
was not political rock Obama because
under the Obama administration AP
reporters and Fox News reporters were
looked into Congress was surveilled
foreign leaders were surveil the sudden
an opposing campaña surveilled and
everyone's saying oh you know what was
that about
much to my chagrin cuz I mean I didn't
like it but you know what they were
after
leaks leaks from the White House and the
emotion and this is exactly what Trump
complains about it leaks and so they
crack down on reporters and wait long I
don't think is legitimate that's what
everything was said about this has been
wrong they said McCabe doesn't leave him
he doesn't leak
no one was surveilled Hillary didn't pay
for the dossier there was no spying
there was no one in the campaign
everything turned out to be wrong just
you know what it is we are at the last
call at the collision occlusion Bar and
Grille and the media and Democrats are
trying to figure out what to do next
alright the shots everybody